is I said what would be your best piece
of advice he said there's a line cross
it mm-hmm
that sounds like a metaphor George give
me something that's more concrete do you
mean I don't want like is that do you
mean touchdown or line crossing or what
does he mean exactly he said he said you
ever read the newspaper watch the news
and call [ __ ] and I said all the
time he said make that your comedy but
make it funny here's a trick raise the
bridge and that was that means raise
your eyebrows when you're delivering
something that you're angry about and
it'll change it from you being angry and
judging maybe this audiences ideals to
this is absurd I don't understand it I'm
confused
interesting Jon Stewart uses it all the
time or did it use it all the time in
yeah on a daily show we'd go this is
crazy
why are they doing this watch Bill Maher
struggles with doing that he tries to
he's like it gets in a weird twitch so
hey how brethren and sistren thanks a
lot for watching this video if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath click the subscribe button to
join the hot breath averse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips